l'urgence dans les chu cd est encore
bien réelle et québec appelle une fois
de plus les médecins spécialistes en
renfort tout ce qui est possible de
reporter ben ça va être reportée parce
que l'urgence nationale c'est d'amener
le plus de monde possible plus
rapidement possible à temps plein dans
nos résidences pour aînés des rapports
qui pourrait mettre la vie de malades en
danger dit certains spécialistes par
exemple les cardiologues crois qu'il
faut recommencer progressivement à
examiner certains patients même s'ils ne
se qualifient pas pour une intervention
d'urgence et plusieurs personnes qui ont
pas d'examens qui pourrait nous
permettre de poser des diagnostics qui
mériterait des interventions de donc ces
personnes là aussi on est content pas on
n'a aucune des combinés can dans la
population et c'est pas négligeable
le président de l'association des
cardiologues a documenté des dizaines de
cas des patients dont l'état de santé
s'est gravement détériorée parce qu'on a
trop tardé à leur offrir des soins c'est
la même inquiétude pour les gens
atteints du cancer
personne n'est plus finalement plusieurs
personnes atteintes d'un cancer qu'un
que le report de certains traitements ne
viennent compromettre leurs chances de
guérir hadopi on a vu que les patients
atteints de cancer ou autre population
souffrait vraiment de dommages
collatéraux et on voyait les taux de
mortalité augmenter les taux de
mortalité non peu vide et augmenter
parce qu'on était tellement concentrée
sur les patients atteints de covin que
les autres la ministre de la santé
assure que les médecins demeurent
disponibles
moi je veux dire à la population puis
surtout aux patients aux gens qui ont
des maladies chroniques aux gens qui ont
un cancer ou qui ont des problèmes
cardiaques
appelez votre médecin appeler votre
spécialiste
il est là pour vous certains médecins
estiment qu'il faut dès maintenant
planifier la reprise de certains soins
pour éviter d'allonger encore plus les
délais d'attentes
ici vincent maisonneuve résout canada
montréal